hey guys what's going on bang bang this
past week was a big one for Bitcoin
first we saw Bitcoin hit a new all-time
high in Argentina this is a great
reminder that many countries around the
world continue to devalue their currency
and Bitcoin is just as important there
as it is here in America and the Western
World on top of that we also saw that
Michael Saylor and microstrategy are no
longer underwater on their Bitcoin
position I don't think that Michael
Saylor and that company were going to
sell their Bitcoin but it still is a
great sign to see because now they can
defend to their shareholders the
decision that they made and hopefully as
the price continues to increase more and
more corporations will realize that this
may be one of the best tour value tools
that they have available to them on top
of that we saw bitcoin's dominance in
the overall crypto market cap continue
to increase and it now is as high as
it's ever been since July 2021. it's a
pretty big deal because it shows that
although Bitcoin is the oldest
cryptocurrency in the world it continues
to be the most popular on top of that we
saw that coinbase is now going to
integrate the lightning Network there
are a number of other exchanges that
have done this in the past but coinbase
being by far the biggest and the one
that most American investors take a look
at if they go ahead and they integrate
the lightning Network it is another data
point that piece of technology and that
network is gaining steam popularity and
I think that a lot of institutional
investors will start to look at it as
well last but not least we also saw that
we have now hit a 50-year low in the
trust in government now of course
there's a lot of things driving that but
when you have something like Bitcoin a
decentralized digital currency that is
not dependent on any one individual
organization or government it tends to
be the type of tool that people turn to
for an alternative one of the things
that I'm paying a lot of attention to
right now is the rise of artificial
intelligence when you think about the
overall theme it's simply automation
Bitcoin is an automated Central Bank and
a lot of the AI tools that we're seeing
launched are simply creating automated
transactions or other types of
automation and daily tasks one of the
things that I believe that will Define
the 21st century is that rise of
Automation and so naturally if we are
going to have daily tasks automated away
it probably makes sense then we're going
to have the monetary policy become
automated as well keep paying attention
there's a lot of work still left to do
but Bitcoin showing positive signs again
for another week in 2023 I'll see all of
you next Saturday